tell me his name again Janice one of the
early decisions we made on infinity war
we knew we wanted to go big the
storyline of infinity war is big the
cast roster and character roster of
infinity war is big the visual effects
the worlds we visit are big the movie
had to seem big and Joe and amp said
let's shoot in IMAX and the question up
to that point was okay well which
sequences is enough the entire movie
should be shot in IMAX
they're fantastic cameras the chip is
incredible that set a resolution that is
unprecedented so I think as filmmakers
it's an amazing tool for us the way that
captures light the way that captures
color in civil war we had a sequence
that took place in an airport and that
really became a test scene for us for a
couple of reasons
the first was we never had that many
characters interacting with each other
before in one sequence it was also a
test for those IMAX cameras to say can
we utilize the sheer enormity of this
frame and the answer quickly was yes it
was the success of that sequence with
all the cast with the IMAX cameras and
with Jonah Anthony Russo directing that
really gave us the confidence to say
let's even embark on infinity war let's
put more characters in it but certainly
have Joe and Anthony directed and let's
use IMAX cameras for the whole thing
[Music]
put a smile in my face
I think if you were to look at the last
ten years as a book of Enders three and
Avengers 4 the final chapters of that
book there are some endings there's some
new beginnings that they're one of the
great values of these movies is like
nobody's ever seen something quite like
them a level of ambition in these phones
are pretty high and we needed equipment
that could help us fulfill that ambition
anytime you know what it's like to lose
feel so desperately that you're right
yet to fail all the same from day one on
a production when the cameras first
start rolling we think about the
audience that is anticipating the
experience that will be buying their
tickets early waiting online if they
have to reserving their seats
sitting that feeder waiting for the
lights to go down and we just think
about one thing and one thing only
delivering on that promise delivering on
that experience and that's the immersive
experience that IMAX gives you when you
lose the rest of the theater you don't
see it all you see is the image and
allows you to be in that world because
that's what we want that's what we want
the audience to experience is to be on
that journey with us with the characters
in is full and rich and immersive away
as possible and that's why I mixed us
I hope they remember you
[Music]
[Music]